In Integrative Doctor recommended I do a three-day water only fast to reset my system, but said I could have three ounces of bone broth each day.
I made it two days and eight hours, and then was having major crappy and diarrhea, and then I looked at what was quick stuff again and realized that you said you should not do bone broth.
What did I do to myself by drinking bone broth? Well, by drinking bone broth two days, I don't think you did anything, so I wouldn't be worried about that.
But you're going to the reason why I don't recommend bone broth for cancerous bone broth.
Bone broth is very healing to the intestinal tract because bone broth is very high in glutamine.
So why is glutamine to heal into the intestinal tract? Because glutamine intensifies the growth of new cells.
So you certainly don't want to intensify growth of new cells, but you have a diagnosis of cancer, so I don't recommend people take glutamine supplements or use bone broth.
And you know, we have cancer, so because we can't do it once in a while, which is, you don't do that on a regular basis.
But I also, you know, I don't have any trouble as you do the three-day fast once in a while, but I don't recommend that on a regular basis, just because it has been shown to impossibly increase actually at run levels too.
So I think you're going to be able to do that on a regular basis.